OK.
Let's now dig further into the idea of what
government should and shouldn't be involved
in, which is a really major part of the conversation
about police departments.
We've already talked about calls to abolish
or defund the police in light of the protests
and the killing of George Floyd.
There's a bigger question implicit in that
discussion, which is what should governments
be involved in and what shouldn't governments
be involved in?
And this is a question that really tracks
political views, because on one side, you
have extreme small government conservatives
and libertarians.
They will sometimes go as far as to say roads
should be privatized.
You can pay the owner to use whichever road
you want or look for a different road.
Another example would be the privatization
of law enforcement, where if you want to be
able to call the police, you pay some kind
of a membership fee to the law enforcement
company that you prefer Google cops or Amazon
police or whatever.
These are extreme examples, but there are
some small government libertarians that believe
this stuff.
On the extreme other hand, you have truly
communist governments where the government
would potentially own all of the industry
and be the sole employer.
They manufacture the vehicles, the government
employs the doctors, owns the hospitals, owns
every restaurant, decides what food rations
people get and what farmers need to do with
the crops that they grow.
These are two extremes.
We have no examples of success in the modern
world for either of the two extremes, because
like with most things, the devil is in the
details.
This is gray area, so let's dig into it.
My starting point as a social Democrat is
that there are many things government should
be doing instead of private industry, but
we should be able to articulate a compelling
reason for why the government should be involved
instead of private industry.
So in other words, government should not be
the only provider of a good or service unless
there is a specific case about why they should
be one of the most important things that governments
should be doing in industries where they are
not participating is setting the ground rules,
which I call regulation.
I don't need government providing, for example,
car insurance, but I do want government saying
to private businesses, if you want to be in
the market of offering car insurance.
Here are the rules you have to abide by.
Similarly, I don't want the government running
airlines and making the airplanes, but I do
want government heavily involved in saying
if you're going to build airplanes, here are
the ground rules.
If you are going to sell tickets to fly, people
around here are the ground rules you need
to adhere to.
Now, most examples are pretty easy to get
agreement on.
For example, very few people believe the government
should be the sole manufacture.
Of mobile phones, and we've got plenty of
companies, Samsung, Apple and others that
are innovating in that space and making mobile
phones, and that's fine.
But we'll get back to mobile phones because
there are complexities that come in when you
introduce externality is which justify the
role of government.
Now, on the other hand, most people do believe
that governments should be responsible for
police departments and law enforcement, missile
defense, defending the country from foreign
attackers, stopping terrorism, et cetera.
And as I mentioned in the other segment, you
might think that it's a good idea to leave
something like human trafficking to nonprofits
and community groups.
But this is stuff with such a massive legal
infrastructure and it's so big and wide ranging.
I do want a properly functioning government
law enforcement apparatus to be dealing with
something like human trafficking correctly.
So the small government versus big government
ideas are very often theoretical.
They're about principles.
But you've got to do way more work to really
figure out how our economy should be organized.
Health care is something I want government
more involved in health care.
There are examples from all over the world
of government being involved in health care
and the health care being better.
Health care is an exception.
As I mentioned, we need a compelling reason
to say this should be pulled out of for profit
markets.
When we're talking about people's health,
I don't believe at a moral level that that
should be something subject to the whims of
companies looking to make profits.
So as a social Democrat, I would say health
care meets the requirement to be pulled out
of for profit market based.
And then you've got gray area.
So, like, I don't need the government running
all the hospitals or employing all the doctors
necessarily.
But maybe I just want them being the insurance
company, negotiating prices, establishing
ground rules, OK?
That that's something that that I would want.
Let me give you another gray area.
I want the government doing lots of infrastructure
spending.
I want them improving our airports and our
roads and our bridges.
I don't need the government running the construction
companies or being the construction company
and buying the bulldozers and the skids steers
and doing it all themselves.
I'm fine with government hiring private industry
to do the actual infrastructure work.
The problem is when the process of hiring
private industry becomes a crony capitalist
snow job where the jobs are given to the president's
friends.
So I'm a social Democrat.
I do think that markets, when they actually
are well regulated and function fairly direct
resources where they are most useful from
a utility point of view.
And sometimes we have to say this area of
society should not be subjected to the market
calculation of where the most utility is derived.
Health being one of those examples.
I don't believe for a second this B.S. that
we hear about industries have incentives to
regulate themselves.
Government doesn't need to regulate because
if the business does something bad, the PR
will be terrible.
News reports about them will make them lose
money.
Just doesn't work, doesn't work.
Consider a company that makes cars and they
pollute and harm some town that's downwind
and people in that town get way more lung
cancer over the 20 years after the cars have
been manufactured.
That's an externality.
Now, you could say, well, the bad PR of people
hearing about that is going to make fewer
people buy that company's cars.
And so the company has an incentive not to
pollute in order to keep selling more cars
and avoid the bad PR just doesn't happen.
These externalities are only often loosely
assignable to a specific action by a company.
Oftentimes, even if the company gets sued,
it is cheaper to pollute and kill a bunch
of people and everyone.
So in a while you just pay some civil lawsuit.
So the point here is the externalities are
not properly dealt with by markets and that
is the role of government regulation.
So the takeaway is I want most areas of life
operating in well regulated markets with the
profits properly taxed to ensure that everyone
has a decent standard of living.
I want industry to operate in a market with
enough safeguards and infrastructure, and
it is not to their advantage to hurt people
in order to earn the profits that they are
earning.
That's why the regulation has to be strict
enough.
And in some cases I actually want the government
participating in the market rather than just
regulating it.
Health care being an exception.
An example of that.
So this stuff is complex.
The principles, people who talk about liberty
and non-aggression and they just want to talk
abstractly.
They often don't want.
Do or aren't able to do the difficult work
of really digging into the specifics.
And you have to do it in order to really get
anywhere on this stuff.
We're going to continue talking about this
on The David Pakman Show Instagram page at
The David Pakman Show.
Make sure you're following The David Pakman
Show, David Pakman dot com.